The DARPA Urban
Challenge promises
to be a stage for innovation
in the areas of robotics,
perception, and planning.
MIT has assembled a team of
top researchers in these fields
and is determined to
win the Grand Challenge.
With that in mind, MIT
has chosen the Land Rover
LR3 because of its unique on-
and off-road capabilities.
The vehicle will rely upon a
layered sensor architecture
that will incorporate
a coupled GPS/INS
system, a series
of redundant LiDAR
scanners for short- to
medium-range sensing,
and several telephoto and
wide-field cameras that
will be used for object
detection in the near and far
field.
While capable
hardware is necessary,
the unique nature of
the upcoming challenge
places the greatest
responsibility on software,
and winning will require a
revolution in the approach
to the problems, ranging
from perception to planning.
Whether you are in
Baghdad or Boston,
uncertainty is implicit in
all aspects of urban driving.
The driver must constantly be
aware of a pedestrian darting
out onto the street or the
car ahead suddenly braking,
as well as replan
routes on the fly
to deal with unexpected
road construction.
Uncertainty will similarly
extend to all aspects
of the DARPA Grand Challenge.
MIT will take advantage
of its unique research
and statistical state
estimation and mapping,
planning under uncertainty,
and statistical perception
in developing a software
architecture that addresses
uncertainty at all levels
of the perception, planning,
and control tasks.
At the high level,
our architecture
will include a mission planner
that manages the global plan,
a situational planner that
is designed to rapidly handle
the uncertainty of
the environment,
and a perceptual
state estimator that
extracts salient
information from the scene.
A map fragment database
maintains a history
of the relevant scene
structure and allows
the technical planner to
be more aggressive when
revisiting areas.
This simulation shows a
motion planning technique
applied to a sample RNDF.
Under nominal
conditions, the planner
chooses the shortest
path to the goal,
but is able to replant on the
fly when an obstruction arises.
In the multi-vehicle
case, our algorithms
predict the motion of other
agents and replan short horizon
trajectories in order to
avoid conflicting paths.
The path planning relies
on a condensed description
of the environment
provided by the sensors.
Similarly, our current
vision research
is capable of real-time,
3D tracking of features
and shapes, which then provides
rich and salient information
about the environment.
With video, we identify
long-range movement
with particles
that capture motion
that is spatially dense
and temporally long-range.
The obstacles can
then be tracked
using robust and
optimized vision
methods that take into account
the structure of the scene.
In this mockup, the
system separates the road
shown in blue from the obstacles
shown in red and extracts
in the far field a sign which,
in turn, impacts the driving
behavior.
Additionally, the mapping
component of this system
will draw upon our current
research in localization
and mapping, which
has been demonstrated
in large, complex environments.
MIT, in conjunction
with Olin College,
currently has the skills
in hardware development
and construction
necessary to implement
these unique algorithms.
Work by team members previously
at the iRobot corporation
demonstrates the ability to
deploy autonomous vehicles
that operate in rugged,
outdoor terrain.
Common both to on-road
and urban driving,
puddles are one
challenging feature,
as they are not easily detected
by standard laser range-finder
technology.
Driving in an urban environment
will require highly precise
navigation at the local scale.
Using the NavCom system, we can
accurately control the vehicle
based upon an IMU and by
directly incorporating
occasional GPS data, can
achieve centimeter precision.
Here, the system uses
the vehicle's own motion
to recover three-dimensional
information from the plane
or laser range data
of the vehicle.
Some vehicle poses can cause
a ground plane to appear
as an obstacle to the system.
Here, we show that the
vehicle slows down in order
to ensure that the
perceived obstacle
during the downward pitch
is, in fact, the ground
plane before continuing
at high speed.
Part of the DARPA
Challenge requires ability
to park between stationary,
unmodeled vehicles.
Here, we see a vehicle
demonstrating a similar ability
by autonomously pulling into
an orchard lane using a fusion
GPS/LiDAR wheel
odometer InVision.
GPS is used to identify
the approximate location
of the lane opening, after
which local sensors take over
for navigation.
Another critical capability
required for the DARPA
Challenge is
sensing and tracking
of other moving vehicles.
Here, we see the ATV
tracking the moving vehicles
ahead of it using only a
single laser range-finder
and a color camera.
MIT has a long-standing
history of building autonomous
platforms for a wide
range of environments
that have successfully helped
to pave the way for the maturing
field of robotics.
We are looking
forward to applying
our technical experience to
the 2006 DARPA Urban Challenge.